the earthquake and tsunami that hit
Japan five years ago killed 16,000
people and caused a meltdown at the
Fukushima Daiichi nuclear power plant
releasing massive amounts of radiation
and resulting in the worst nuclear
disaster since Chernobyl tens of
thousands of people evacuated their
homes and most of them haven't been able
to return cleaning up the disaster may
take up to 40 years the plant
contaminates 300 to 400 tons of water
every day there are thousand tanks at
the plant holding more than 700,000 tons
of contaminated water that's equivalent
to almost 300 Olympic sized swimming
pools and there's no clean plan on how
to store the water safely the first of
seven towns that were entirely evacuated
finally reopened in September 2015 but
less than two percent of residents
returned that month the others were
afraid of lingering radiation or had
moved on with their lives